today on the matt welsh show we're told
that the impending decision on roe v
wade will help the democrats because it
will galvanize their base around the
abortion issue but as we've seen over
the last couple days abortion is
actually the last issue democrats want
to talk about and we'll talk about why
that is also rachel levine at hhs says
that there is no argument against
castrating children democrats uh also
actually want trump back on twitter
according to a new report i wonder why
that is in our daily cancellation an
obese woman fights for greater plus-size
representation in the travel industry
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the matt wells show
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a difficult time for business
owners especially small business owners
and that's why you need every advantage
you can find especially when it comes to
marketing and that's why you need
constant contact for constant contact is
a digital marketing platform that helps
small businesses and non-profits of all
sizes build grow and succeed with email
marketing contact management industry
leading list growth tools social media
ads and more content constant contact
helps small businesses connect with
customers find new ones and sell online
all from one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing with a 97 deliverability rate
you can rest assured that your customers
and potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time with a
simple interface constant contacts easy
to use platform makes contact management
easier than ever their list growth tools
help you find a bigger audience fast
lead generation landing pages text to
join and social media ads are proven to
grow your list and drive engagement with
your brand with thousands of
integrations you can sync constant
contacts tools with the tools you're
already using powerful automation tools
help you send the right message to the
right person at the right time
to start your free digital marketing
trial today visit constantcontact.com
so the popular wisdom that's formed
around the leak of the roe v wade
decision a leak that chief justice john
roberts confirmed as authentic yesterday
no surprise is that um overturning roe
would actually help the democrats
ultimately by galvanizing their base
before the midterms it's pointed out
that according to most polling data a
majority of americans do not want roe
overturned supposedly but
it's always a precarious thing i think
to trust popular wisdom in a society so
bereft of wisdom popular wisdom is
simply the wisdom of the unwise and
that's certainly the case here first of
all
of course even if it happened to be true
that overturning roe and abolishing the
mythical constitutional right to
abortion would help democrats it would
still be worth doing i mean even if
overturning roe would tear our country
into and precipitate a civil war it
would still be worth doing in fact some
might argue that the latter scenario
would be an added benefit of overturning
it
some might argue that anyway i'm just
saying some people might think that the
point is that the first and most
fundamental priority is to save the
lives of innocent children there is no
cost too heavy to pay literally no cost
i would accept any consequence at all if
it meant rescuing even one child from
the hands of the butchers
but as it happens it is not true that
overturning roe will help the democrats
it's not true because for one thing if
democrat voters are galvanized they're
not going to be the only ones
this pushes the abortion issue back down
to the states which means that
republican voters will finally now have
the power to elect people who can fully
outlaw abortion in their states this is
an ability a power that pro-life voters
have
most anyway have never had
the roe decision by design took the
power out of the hands of pro-life
voters and that was the whole point
how could putting power back into their
hands be somehow what demoralizing
or only galvanizing the people on the
opposite side of the issue that makes no
sense
but there's another reason
why this turn of events will not help
the democrats
despite the popular wisdom
if this issue is still at the top of the
stack by the time the midterms roll
around and that's a big if because
there's a better than 50 chance that the
whole issue will be 300 news cycles in
the past by then and nobody will be
talking about it anymore because no one
can talk about anything or focus on
anything for more than you know 30
seconds at a time
but if it's still somehow above the fold
at that point that will not actually be
a good thing for the democrats because
that means that democrat politicians
within close proximity of an election
will have to talk about abortion and
they don't actually want to talk about
abortion that's the dirty little secret
here
they want their voters to be motivated
by the fear of quote-unquote anti-choice
republicans trying to take their quote
bodily autonomy away but they want to
stoke this fear in very generalized and
very vague sorts of ways
they don't want to actually talk about
abortion itself
they certainly don't want to get into
the nitty-gritty of what they really
believe on this issue because when they
do it quickly becomes apparent that
their views on the subject fall into two
categories and only two categories and
usually both at once one incoherent and
two barbaric
the entire democrat strategy with
respect to abortion is built around the
effort to make sure that voters don't
notice these two facts
and that means being very circumspect
about abortion and not dwelling on the
issue for very long
the polls may indicate that most
americans quote unquote support abortion
but that's only because a rather support
row that's what the polls indicate that
they support roe but that's only because
most americans don't understand roe or
what it actually entails
which isn't fully their fault i mean
they've got the entire media apparatus
which is trying to confuse them about it
a majority of those same americans also
support sweeping restrictions on
abortions whereas roe was designed to
eliminate those restrictions
there is an incoherence to the average
american's view on the subject and
that's what democrats want to maintain
as always
they don't necessarily need or want you
to agree with their views they just want
you to be confused
now agreeing with them is great if they
can get it but
if they can't get it then they'll take
confusion
that's a fine runner-up prize as far as
they're concerned
once abortion becomes the topic of
conversation as it is right now
for however long that remains the case
the barbarism and incoherence of the
left-wing position comes to the
forefront
one of the most uh one of the best i
think most famous most infamous examples
of this happened back in 2019 when
virginia virginia democrats were pushing
for a bill that would legalize abortion
through every phase of pregnancy up
until birth
and lots of other states have um have
bills like this on the books now
in exchange in the virginia house of
delegates between republican delegate
todd gilbert and democrat delegate kathy
tran i think illustrates the problem for
democrats when they're put on the spot
and they're forced to actually explain
their real position on the subject
they're exposed as the incomprehensible
monsters that they truly are so let's go
back and watch that again to refresh our
memories and this again is why democrats
do not actually want to talk about this
and especially don't want to talk about
it when they're headed into an election
watch this
delegate tran yes sir how late in a
pregnancy would your bill apply
if a physician would simply willing to
certify that
that the
continuation of the pregnancy would
impair the mental health of of the woman
how how late are we talking about well
so
so the way the suggestion that we've um
made in the bill is to say it's in the
third uh trimester and at the you know
with the certification of the physician
so so how late in the third trimester
would you be able to to do that
you know and it's very unfortunate that
our physicians uh witnesses were not
able to attend today to speak
specifically i'm talking about your bill
how late in the third trimester could a
physician perform an abortion if he
indicated it would impair the mental
health of the of the woman
or physical health
okay okay i'm talking about the mental
health
so i mean through the third trimester
the third trimester goes all the way up
to 40 weeks okay but to the end of the
third trimester yep i don't think we
have a limit in the bill so
um
where it's obvious that a woman is about
to give birth she has physical signs of
that she is about to give a birth
would that still be a point at which she
could request an abortion if she was so
certified
she's dilating
mr chairman that would be a you know a
decision that the doctor the physician
and the woman i understand that i'm
asking if your bill allows that
my bill would allow that yes
so this was her bill
but she didn't want to talk about it
this issue that's supposedly what good
for the left they the democrats and it's
going to motivate their voters and they
don't want to talk about it she don't
want to talk about the fact that yes
it would have made it legal
to kill a fully developed infant child
in the womb
seconds before birth
she also didn't want to talk about the
fact that when democrats say that
abortion might be necessary to protect
the health of the mother
that also includes mental health
that's really what they mean
is if a woman says that her mental
health will suffer because she'll be sad
about having a baby well uh that's an
example if she gets an abortion in that
case well that's also an example of a of
abortion saving the life of the mother
these are the kinds of ugly realities
that come out whenever the nation's
attention is focused on this issue
democrats are simply not able to speak
for more than one or two sentences about
abortion without devolving into savagery
and nonsense
and that's certainly been the case over
the last two days as well um let's uh
look at a few examples and speaking of
not being able to speak for more than
one or two sentences let's start with
president biden giving his take on the
supreme court's draft decision and i
want you to listen to the words that he
uses
so the idea that we're going to make a
judgment
that
is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
abort a child he says
the democrat position on this subject is
so horrifying that just simply hearing
someone say it out loud
abort a child
makes your hair stand on end
you also see there how much it pains
biden to be talking about this at all he
spends most of his answer filibustering
you know treading water trying to avoid
even saying the word abort
the idea that we're going to make a
judgment that is going to say that no
one can make the judgment to choose to
abort a child
now granted biden's brain is just a bowl
of grits at this point but this is
pretty standard for the left when it
comes to this issue
case in point another case in point
anyway listen to whoopi goldberg on the
view yesterday listen to this
this is my body
and nobody
you you know you've got people telling
me i gotta wear a mask or don't wear a
mask or do this everybody wants to tell
me what to do but you won't let me make
my decision about my body you are not
the person to make that decision my
doctor and my self and my child that's
who makes the decision and one of the
things i really want to point out before
we go is the reason abortion came about
women in this country
lived forever with it being illegal
okay
women when they decide
something is not right for them they're
going to take it into their own hands
well we got tired of tripping over women
in bathrooms public bathrooms who were
giving themselves abortions because
there was nowhere safe nowhere clean
nowhere to go
this law came about because people
wanted people to have somewhere safe and
somewhere clean it has nothing to do
with your religion this is not a
religious issue this is a human issue if
you care about me as a as a human being
you should know three things getting an
abortion is not easy making that
decision is not easy
we have to stop it there even though she
has two other things on her list
there's already too much nonsense to
sort through that was 78 seconds so she
had 78 seconds to talk about abortion
and she couldn't get through it without
venturing repeatedly into the realm of
horrifying nonsense
first she says that an abortion is this
is a decision
that should be left up to myself my
doctor
and my child
so what the child consents to the
abortion now this is consensual butchery
are we pretending that the child is
consulted and agrees to have its body
torn apart limb from limb that was 28
seconds in from there she claims that
before row you couldn't go into a
women's restroom without tripping over
women laying all over the floor giving
themselves abortions with coat hangers
that's what she wants us to believe
and now that she's in the realm of the
hallucinatory she actually points to
something that's true she says that
getting an abortion is not easy
that again that's true
i mean it comes at a great cost
women suffer immensely before during and
after their abortions but why whoopi
why isn't it easy
why do women suffer so much from their
abortions if abortion simply extracts a
blob of
lifeless meaningless tissue
why
why would it
be so painful why isn't it easy
you know if you have um
a wart on your skin or something and you
go and get that blob of tissue removed
that's not that's pretty easy
nobody will be talking about the
emotional trauma involved there
so why is it hard
she doesn't want to answer that she
can't
she can't talk about it beyond the
blathering nonsense you just heard and
yet it helps democrats when abortion is
the number one issue
this thing that they can't talk about
and when it comes to disturbing
gibberish that we hear from the left
about abortion we certainly cannot
neglect to acknowledge
this moment on msnbc yesterday here's
yamiche alcindor alleged journalist
giving her perspective listen to this
you'll always be able to get an abortion
because you'll be able to fly to one of
what they're calling the 13 safe states
places that might continue to have
abortion like california or new york but
for a lot of vulnerable women women who
are poor women who are women women of
color they will be forced to have
pregnancies that they cannot afford to
terminate and pregnancies that will then
turn into children
forced to have pregnancies that turn
into children forced to have pregnancies
that turn into children
what were they before they turned into
children were they
turtles before that kangaroos space
aliens
what was the woman pregnant with
before the point when the pregnancy
turned into a child
this of course makes no sense whatsoever
and only the most oblivious americans
could fail to notice how nonsensical it
is and here we're only focusing on the
turn into a child bit but the part right
before that is just as stupid she says
um
forced to have pregnancies
who's forcing women to have pregnancies
less than one percent of abortions are
due to rape
and that those statistics by the way are
from like the guttmacher institute
pro-abortion
give us those statistics
so we could be pretty sure that the
actual number is smaller than even what
they tell us let's just go with one
percent for the sake of argument
for the other 99 plus percent
these are women who get pregnant
after choosing to participate in the
reproductive act
they did a thing through their own free
will and volition which has literally
billions of times in the past resulted
in pregnancy
they chose to participate in this
activity in the 99 of cases
nobody forced anything so so who forced
them to be pregnant nature god who's the
culprit here
what are you talking about
abortion doesn't turn back the clock or
undo what's been done
abortion doesn't erase the pregnancy
one way or another if a woman is
pregnant eventually the pregnancy must
come to an end it can end naturally
usually through the birth of a child or
it can be ended through violence
violence against another living being
our position as pro-lifers is that once
a woman becomes pregnant it is not
acceptable to commit violence against
the living being in the womb no matter
how she feels about the pregnancy
that's our position and it's clear we're
not ashamed of it we'll say it out loud
clearly we don't have we don't need you
know recourse to euphemism
the left hides behind euphemism and code
words and gibberish because they're
terrified to let you see the hideous
truth at the core of their position
and that's why already
many of them are changing the subject
changing it in quite desperate and
hilarious ways here's uh eric swalwell
congressman and infamous public farter
tweeting he says
the republicans won't stop with banning
abortion
they want to ban interracial marriage
do you want to save that well then you
should probably vote
ban interracial marriage what how did
that get introduced into the
conversation
and what republican has advocated
banning interracial marriage i want to
know which republican has stood on the
floor of the senate or the house of
representatives
and said that we need to ban interracial
marriage
and how have we not heard about that
if that happened
one of the conservative justices on the
court clarence thomas is in an
interracial marriage does he want to ban
his own marriage
what is he babbling about
well he's just trying to change the
subject
because he wants to talk about any
subject
other than the subject at hand
and don't be fooled
that's what they all want
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know identity theft may sound
complicated uh and maybe it sounds like
something you don't have to worry about
but in some cases all a thief needs to
carry out a shopping scam is your name
mailing address email address and phone
number and it's not hard for them to get
those details and with those details
they can start an online store account
but add their own shipping info then
they purchase items on accounts without
your knowledge leaving you only with
collections notices it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives this is
just one of the ways of many every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes even
harm your finances your credit your
reputation your whole life basically
good thing there's life luck lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale in the dark web if they detect
your information has potentially been
compromised they'll send you an alert
and you also have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you become a
victim so you have on both ends you have
protection nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
um
by the way i also wanted to mention you
know that that would be go like i said
dopey goldberg clip there's just so much
it's hard to sift through everything and
point to every
part of every every little piece of it
that was incorrect or false or you know
fallacious
um but one other
point
worth worth making here is that she says
oh this is not about religion don't
bring your religion into it
and of course
every time abortion comes up
this is what we hear from the left
don't bring religion oh get get your
religion out of my uterus and so on and
so forth
but you notice something
they are always the ones who bring
religion into it they bring religion
into it by telling us to keep religion
out of it
but most of us we're not talking about
religion
we now it's true
that um
that
if you are a christian
like it's not possible actually to be a
christian and be pro-abortion that's
true
um because our faith absolutely forbids
murdering innocent people including and
especially children
but that's
we we don't
the argument against abortion
is universal and simple
um we don't need to make it into a
theological conversation and we're not
the ones who do that
in fact the left they're the ones who
bring up religion in two ways they bring
it up by telling us to keep religion out
of it
and actually ironically here if anyone
in the abortion conversation is going to
bring up religion to justify their
position it's almost always the left
that's where you hear
uh joe biden and all these alleged
pro-abortion catholics saying my
religion calls me to they're the ones
who do that
and why do they do it it's because again
they're just scrambling to say anything
do anything to put as much distance as
they can in between the issue
and themselves and you know they want to
put distance between the issue and the
conversation and so if they can make the
conversation about religion they'll do
that if they can make it about
interracial marriage they'll do that
if they can make it about gay marriage
which is uh which is another thing we're
seeing from the left next they're going
to go after gay marriage
anything they can do
to put distance they're going to do that
a couple other clips i want to play here
um
camilla harris
spoke out yesterday and and uh here she
is
doing her best impression of a normal
human being and who's uh she's she's
trying to
sort of pretend to be angry she's trying
to generate
feelings of anger and let's see how she
does
women would lose access to abortion
immediately and outright
those republican leaders who are trying
to weaponize the use of the law against
women
will we say
how dare they
how dare they tell a woman what she can
do and cannot do with her own body
[Applause]
how dare they
how dare they try to stop her from
determining her own future
how dare they
try to deny women
their rights
and their freedoms
uh just more
transphobia from the left we have to
keep pointing this out that you know i i
we have to keep putting it out because
we can't let them get away with this
they're gonna try to do it they are
doing it right now but we can't just let
them get away with it
um there are many reasons why everything
she said there is wrong and stupid and
dishonest but
also you can't do this anymore camila
that's out the window for you you're not
a lot this is not
you can't do it
you've ruled this out
you've given this up this whole thing
about his attack on women that's out the
window because women don't exist
according to you according to your world
you have your worldview has erased women
from existence
they're gone according to you
now where does that leave you as a woman
i don't know you're just some sort of
like phantom walking
the earth i i don't know i mean i can't
make sense of it it's your worldview not
mine
in my worldview women certainly exist
but in yours they don't so you can't do
this i'm not going to allow it we can't
allow it
that's why on the right we should not
engage with this attack on women we
should not engage with that
claim
beyond simply asking what's a woman what
are you talking about
again there are many other ways we could
engage with it
but we shouldn't instead it's just i
don't i don't even know what you're
saying what in the world are you talking
about
how could this be an attack on women
are you suggesting that women have some
particular special
capacity to give birth to bring new life
into the world
are you suggesting that this is uh that
this is a a unique special aspect of
womanhood
well what a what a transphobic
horrendous thing to say
we got the same routine from elizabeth
warren who was also pretending to be
upset let's play clip
14.
i am
[Applause]
i am angry
because an extremist
united states supreme court
thinks that they can impose
their extremist views on all of the
women of this country and they are wrong
i am angry
because we have reached the culmination
of what republicans have been fighting
for angling for
for decades now and we are gonna fight
somebody get grandmother over to uh to
at home she's
losing her mind i mean there's there's
something especially just repulsive in
particular about well about all
you know the entire pro-abortion side
but
in particular these old bitter
boomer
feminists
who are reaching you know the end of
their
the end of their days i mean they're
they're in the certainly the the latter
part of their their lives and um
they have already overseen people like
elizabeth warren who's what in her 90s
or something whatever she is
they've already overseen the slaughter
the mass slaughter of 60 million babies
and they're not
satisfied i mean their bloodlust has not
been quenched
they want even more babies to be killed
i mean just imagine being you're a
grandmother
and you're angry
you're screeching i mean she sounds like
some creature that you hear in the woods
at night
especially around here in tennessee i go
take the garbage out and we're
surrounded by woods and just hear all
these sounds
it's like it's like elizabeth warren
must be in the woods it's what she
sounds like she's she is reduced to this
guttural
howling and screeching this demonic
uh hysteria
sure it reminds me of that uh either
either a creature in the woods at night
or maybe better yet the scene and the
passion of the christ
um
after uh
you know when you see after christ
conquers death uh and the resurrection
and and uh and then we
we cut to a scene of satan just howling
in hell and that's what she reminds me
of
and this is what they're grandmothers
and this is what they're doing
they barely even they've just you're
looking at someone who has
forfeited her humanity
a soulless husk
pretty disturbing
all right
let's move to this this is from the
daily wire uh more disturbing news for
you if you wanted some more the highest
ranking transgender person the by
administration who was also a
pediatrician claimed there is no
argument among medical professionals
about the value and the importance of
gender affirming care is speaking to the
national public radio admiral rachel
levine the u.s assistant secretary for
health used the opportunity to attack
florida surging general joseph ladapo an
ally of florida gop governor ron
desantis levine accused lodapo of
putting out a statement based upon
political considerations that is not
appropriate
ladapo had released a fact sheet on
april 20th that stated uh it would
clarify evidence recently cited on a
fact sheet released by the u.s
department of health and human services
um
and now the
health and human services rachel levine
and he's coming out and saying not just
that it's acceptable to perform chemical
castration on children and to sterilize
children but actually that there's
there's no argument about it whatsoever
and the response i've heard from the
right
to this
is that uh well that's that's absurd
that's ridiculous so of course there's
there's arguments within the medical
community about this
but
actually rachel levine in this case is
more right than we would like to think
not right about it being acceptable or
okay to do that to kids obviously that
is uh that's
child abuse that's worse than child
abuse and everybody involved should go
to prison forever
but
in terms of the the medical communi
community the medical industry
there is now almost
unanimous agreement
because they've pushed all the
dissenting voices out
and whatever descending voices could
still remain within that community have
mostly been silenced or they have
silenced themselves out of fear and
cowardice i mean remember i i have to
keep um emphasizing this because i i
just
i i feel like we're not we're not
focusing on it quite quite enough it was
the american academy of pediatrics last
week that put out that book
um promoting you know a book for kids
which was charting on the children's
bestseller list
below my own book by the way my book was
uh
actually we just found out from amazon
side note that's um
according to amazon charts john the
walrus was the number one book in the
entire country last week so that was
good news
and uh this disgusting book from the
american academy of pediatrics was below
that but even so
american academy pediatrics that was
their book promoting puberty blockers
chemical castration sterilization for
kids
okay and that's is in terms of the
medical community
that's as mainstream as you can possibly
get
and so when rachel levine claims
when he says that there's no argument
that you know within within the medical
community
it is a it is a shame and an outrage
that that is almost almost true there
are exceptions
but they are few and far between
which does not at all even a little bit
serve to legitimize
this kind of butchery that's done to
children and the drugging doesn't
certainly legitimize it what it does
unfortunately is serve to further
delegitimize the medical industry
they have delegitimized themselves
by putting politics and putting ideology
and uh and also putting their own
professional advancement
above
their oath
to do no harm
you know to treat not to harm they've
they've put politics ideology personal
advancement above all of that far above
it
whereas the actual what is supposed to
be the actual purpose of medicine is now
it's not even an afterthought in many of
these cases
and especially when it comes to gender
confused children
it's not an afterthought you know the
idea of like actually helping these kids
and treating
whatever ails them
and most of the time what's ailing them
it's a mental thing and it's not even a
mental illness it's just confusion
and understandable confusion given the
environment they're in and so treating
them doesn't require drugs doesn't it
doesn't even require intense therapy in
many of these cases
it's just sitting them down and telling
them the truth and explaining it
um but no it's that's not an
afterthought that's just that's not a
thought at all
that's not anywhere on the radar they're
not going to do that for these kids
um let's see what else we got here
uh
from the daily wire little nas x has
been criticized for promoting his songs
to a young audience and then releasing
music that's only suitable for adults
the 23 year old rapper whose real name
is montero lamar hill insisted he was
free to change his target audience
whenever he wants now he's back to
targeting the kids music market by
inviting the wiggles to go on tour with
him
uh he shared on twitter last week trying
really hard to get the wiggles to
co-headline the tour with me i'll keep
you guys updated
and um
and i actually found out about this
last week before the uh
for the ly reported on it because my
wife
you know has been historically a big fan
of the wiggles and she's inflicted that
on me over the course of you know the
last eight years with each successive
kid she's tried to indoctrinate them
into the wiggles and so i've got the
songs about fruit salad and big red car
and all this kind of stuff i have to
endure and listen to in the car and
everything and she saw this and was very
upset i don't know if the wiggles um
have access accepted this invitation or
not
but this only goes to show this little
not little nas x guy you want to talk
about groomers and predators
in hollywood and in the music industry
like predator groomer number one he's
he's
blatant about it
and completely unapologetic
a lot of the other groomers and
predators they at least pretend to be
offended when you accuse them of that
they pretend that they're doing
something else oh we're not doing that
for him it's out in the open
i mean he came onto the scene
trying to cultivate a fan base of
not just kids but very young kids like
elementary school aged kids he went and
performed at elementary schools and he
was on nickelodeon all this kind of
stuff
and then he went immediately
from that to
uh giving a lap dance to satan
right to there
and
and then you and then people that want
to defend him his defenders said well
he's just he's he's free to make that
kind of transition
he's free to make the transition from
singing elementary schools to lap
dancing on
satan
uh this is just it's a it's a it's the
evolution of his career
yeah except now he's circling back
around and trying to recruit
um this children's
musical group
to perform with him on on uh on stage
so this is very much
an out in the open attempt to sexualize
groom
prey upon
kids uh one of the quick thing i want to
mention is from the washington examiner
says white house officials are letting
it be known that they desire twitter to
invite back former president donald
trump conflicting with earlier reports
the occupants of 1600 pennsylvania
avenue are reportedly warming up to the
idea that president joe biden might
benefit if elon musk should uh
his 44 billion dollar takeover twitter b
be finalized immediately reverses the
ban on biden's 2020 rival
beyond casting the republican party as a
hostage to right-wing extremists the
other thing white house officials are
cheering for a number of them said over
the weekend that if elon musk indeed
takes over twitter they hope the first
thing he does is put donald trump back
on it
and the reason they want donald trump
back on twitter is because they think it
works to their advantage to have you
know to have this kind of immediate
access to donald trump's stream of
consciousness they think it works they
think that his tweeting works to their
advantage and they want him back on
twitter and i've been saying this from
day one
that they pretended they wanted trump
off of twitter but they never actually
wanted that and they do want him back on
because it works more to their benefit
to have now this reveals that of course
once again that everything they say is
is fake and not true and uh they're just
pretending because you know everything
they say oh donald trump is dangerous we
can't have his rhetoric no they they
want it out there because they think it
benefits them
so it goes to show that but it also
shows how you know and i actually agree
with them
that i think trump back on twitter
benefits democrats more than it benefits
republicans i know there are a lot of
republicans and conservatives cheering
for it they want trump back on twitter
um
i think he should be allowed back on
twitter
i think the idea that the sitting
president united states was ever kicked
off a twitter in the first place is just
utter madness
and even now as a former president it's
still madness
but as of right now trump says that
if he's allowed back on he's not going
to
he's not going to accept the invitation
because he wants to use his platform
truth social and um i i i hope that he
sticks with that
because i think ultimately it just it
what it means it means a lot of things
but mainly it means that if you got
trump on twitter
tweeting all the time
it means that the democrats anytime they
want can just take one of his tweets and
make that the story anytime they want to
distract from something and we saw this
through
four years five years
anytime they want to distract from
something there was a there was a new
cycle that wasn't going their way
just take one of his tweets and he
always had there was always a a stream
of new tweets that they could choose
from say their pick of the litter take
one and that's the story oh look at this
mean thing he tweeted
now i think they got diminishing returns
on that from a pr perspective
but even so it's a it is still a
diversion
mechanism
for them that works in their favor
if you've been listening to my show for
a while you're probably familiar with
one of our top sponsors we're very happy
and proud to have on the show rock otto
well recently my producer mckenna
told me about her own experience
shopping with rock otto and how great it
was for her
and it's such a great story we're going
to tell it to you again mckenna was
carpooling with her boyfriend during an
ice storm and turned on his windshield
wipers before he got in the car to help
get rid of the ice but with this simple
act she destroyed her windshield wipers
they had to drive in the rain with
wipers that barely could wipe the rain
away during the drive to work she
figured it was worth checking
rockauto.com to see if they had
replacement options for the windshield
wipers and sure enough she was able to
buy some new windshield wipers for the
car that are made to deal with ice and
for a surprisingly reasonable price so
if you're like mckenna i need a quick
fix or if you need to do some major
repairs you should check out
rockauto.com once you go to rockauto.com
a list will guide you through every
single make and model you could possibly
imagine all you have to do is quickly
find your car and rock auto will give
you a list of every part available for
your vehicle included with the part
descriptions are photos and specs so you
can feel confident you're choosing the
correct parts so go to rockauto.com for
your auto part needs today and write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that i'm the one that
sent you that's rockauto.com for your
auto part needs today
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
here's a message from stephen l who says
i find it hilarious that conservatives
whined about doxing libs of tick tock
but now want to dox the supreme court
leaker
uh yeah well that's
not even close to the same thing at all
um
libs of tick tock was
a
twitter account and anonymous twitter
account
that posted
tick tock videos on twitter that's what
libsa tiktok was is
um and posted other things too
but primarily
that's why we call libs of tick tock
the person who leaked supreme court
documents that is somebody who works
within the supreme court
who's taking these what are right now
confidential documents
putting them out in public
in an unprecedented historic move
in order to intimidate
uh supreme court justices and influenced
the outcome of a supreme court case
okay so this is two completely different
things in the case of like it's not
newsworthy nobody needs to know
the identity of the person who's posting
tick tock videos on twitter
it is very newsworthy the identity of
the person working within the supreme
court whoever it is
who's trying to influence supreme court
decisions uh and intimidate supreme
court justices by leaking these these
documents very newsworthy
and it's more than newsworthy it's it's
uh
relevant to law enforcement i mean this
is someone who needs to be flushed out
and at least fired and i think also
prosecute
so you're really reaching there i got to
say
um
rose says matt what about the theory
that a conservative leaked the decision
in order to stop one of the five and the
majority from defecting basically
locking them into place
yeah i don't i don't buy that at all uh
first of all a conservative if we're
talking about a clerk here
which i guess this is the assumption is
that some clerk in the supreme court is
the one who leaked this
and uh which
it's i think it's almost certain
that it was a clerk who communicated
with this person over at politico
whether or not an actual justice was
involved and coordinated this that i i
don't know and i wouldn't be surprised
if that was the case
um
but as far as the idea that a
conservative did it first of all a
conservative would not do this to their
own people their own side
and just as a matter of strategy it has
a much greater chance of backfiring
than actually working out because now
you're
so what's what's the idea here you have
you've got five in the majority they're
going to overturn roe
and then you leak this decision
and you know that it's going to lead to
harassment and intimidation of those
justices so there's a very good chance
you're going to scare one of them away
from the decision they would have
otherwise made
so i don't think a conservative would do
this to their own side it also doesn't
make any sense from a strategic
standpoint and then and then the biggest
thing here and the number one reason why
we know it wasn't a conservative did
this is that it was leaked to politico
okay conservative leaking to politico
they might as well leak to the
huffington post or like the feminist
blog jezebel it's the same kind of thing
that's how you know they would not they
would not
be leaking this to politico
they wouldn't entrust their anonymity to
some leftist over politico
because by doing this you know you're
putting your career on the line at the
very least you might be putting your
freedom on the line if you get uh
criminally prosecuted
and a conservative is going to trust
politico to keep that a secret
no way
no way at all
gergie says lesbians and postmenopausal
women freaking out over abortion law is
just beyond ludicrous yeah we talked
about that before that's one of the
reasons why it's why it's ridiculous and
that's also what makes one of the
reasons what makes it that makes it even
more repulsive when you see people like
elizabeth warren panicking over this
like it doesn't even affect them
personally
because
there's no risk of you having a baby
um
but they just feel so passionate it's
like they hate babies that much
it's not just their own potential babies
they hate it's they just hate babies
and they're filled with rage at least
with the younger feminists
it's all it's all very self-centered and
it's it's narcissistic and
they're worried that they might be
forced god forbid
to be responsible for their own actions
and all of that
um
but yeah again with these older women
that's that's not the case for them it's
simply hatred of babies hatred of human
life
this kind of demonic rage that i think
animates and motivates them
um
melor dankness says hey matt just got to
know
i have to know where on earth you get
your sock subscription i've been
listening to your videos for a while and
i'm finally catching up
well some sad news there my wife
recently i found out canceled my sock
subscription
um
which is reason enough really maybe that
should be a daily cancellation at some
point
uh it was a company called southern
scholar and they sell socks for
gentlemen which i am one that's how they
advertise themselves and this is not a
paid promotion at all but
if you're a sock enthusiast like i am
then i definitely check them out and get
your sock subscription
you know the daily wire has accomplished
a lot this year including an
announcement of our new platform dw kids
we're taking on disney hollywood uh even
razor companies and rebuilding the
culture that the left has been handily
destroying because it's about time we do
something so you can as well stop giving
money to organizations that don't
respect you or your values help us build
alternatives where the left is tearing
down foundations we're building things
they're tearing things down that's the
way that goes and you can start today
head to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code walsh for 20 off and join us in our
fight to preserve real american values
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
unfortunately we have to deal with a
heavy topic for the daily cancellation
today it's heavy uh but it's also um
a big topic and one that can be
difficult to fully kind of wrap your
arms around here's the story from the
daily mail they report that a morbidly
obese traveler quote has divided opinion
after sharing a viral tick tock slamming
ryanair for the size of its seats with
some critics telling her it was not the
airline's fault
now it's basically a monthly tradition
at this point that a fat airline
passenger complains on tick tock about
the fact that planes are not being
redesigned to specifically accommodate
their hefty frame uh this is right in
line with those other complaints daily
mail continues kirsty leanne uh
kirstyland29 from shropshire filmed the
clip while flying with the budget
carrier revealing how she struggled to
fit down the plane's narrow aisle
couldn't use the tray table due to lack
of space and could barely move in the
tiny toilet cubicle kirsty who blogs
about her experiences traveling as a
size 24 to 26 wanted to highlight issues
she encounters to others recalling the
problematic flight kirsty explained the
first issue i faced was walking down the
plane aisle i was one of the last people
on the plane because i was running a
little late so i felt the stares of
people all i could think was that they
didn't want me to sit next to them the
plus-size blogger also revealed how she
was unable to do work because she didn't
have space to use the tray table she
said i was going to use the tray table
to do some work on the way but when i
couldn't put it down i quickly decided
that it was not going to happen
meanwhile she continued the bathroom was
another issue i faced unfortunately it's
probably one of the smallest bathrooms
i've ever seen and i decided against
trying to squeeze in
she continues with this horror story in
greater detail but you probably get the
the gist apparently kirstie does this
for a living or at least as a hobby she
travels around and complains when she's
too fat to do certain things according
to her tick tock account
her mission is to push for greater
plus-sized representation in the travel
industry
although you could argue that plus-sized
people already have
you know very large representation
now we've talked plenty of times in the
past about the so-called body positivity
movement which encourages people to
display their positive attitudes about
their bodies by destroying their bodies
this is what makes body positivity one
of the most self-contradictory and also
destructive ideas to come along in quite
some time and it manages to stand out
even amid all the other
self-contradictory destructive ideas
that are so popular these days
but we're not going to dwell
specifically on that aspect of it
we're also going to leave aside the
point that if i'm being honest part of
me actually hopes that the obese
community gets their way plays the
victim card successfully and forces
planes to better accommodate them
because the end result is that we would
all get bigger seats and more legroom i
guess which would be kind of nice of
course that's assuming that the
concession doesn't involve setting aside
a special area on the plane just for fat
people where only they get the extra
room maybe first class will be abolished
and replaced with fat class
fat people will be rewarded with you
know premium first class seats and even
better the first class food
so come to think of it that's actually
probably exactly what would end up
happening so i take back what i said a
moment ago
anyway i want to turn our attention to
another aspect of this situation which
lies a little deeper and you can only
see it when you sort of
trim the fat away no pun intended of
course i'm not the kind of person who
would bring up this discussion
as nothing more than a vehicle to make
fat puns that's not who i am instead i'm
struck by
the important truth about human nature
that this story and stories like it
illustrate for us
after all the fat acceptance movement is
supposed to be all about
freedom right
people should be free to be whatever
size they want and the world's job is to
accommodate their girth however
gargantuan it might be
but as always
our culture promotes a kind of freedom
which is really in the end slavery
when you do whatever you want you
exercise no self-control
you
exercise
not at all in general
and simply follow the whims of the flesh
you end up trapped in a nightmare of
your own making
this woman is so free that you can't
even fit on a plane she's so free that
she can't fully participate in society
she's so free that she's probably going
to die before she reaches the age of 60.
this is the freedom of the modern world
the freedom that makes you a slave to
your compulsions the freedom that leads
ultimately to annihilation
and fat acceptance is just one example
there are many others often quite a bit
more serious how about to return to the
topic of the day
the freedom granted to women to kill
their unborn children
this is a freedom that deprives you of
something good and true and fulfilling
it deprives a woman of herself in many
ways it deprives her of the opportunity
to be transformed by the love for and
from her child
it robs her of everything
consigns her to a life of regret and
loss and guilt
and then we call it
freedom
dostoevsky noticed this about the modern
world way back in the 1800s when he
wrote the brothers karamazov which
includes this passage
he writes the world has proclaimed the
reign of freedom especially of late but
what do we see in this freedom of theirs
nothing but slavery and self-destruction
for the world says
you have desires and so satisfy them for
you have the same rights as the most
rich and powerful don't be afraid of
satisfying them and even multiplying
your desires
that is the modern doctrine of the world
in that they see freedom
and what follows from this rite of
multiplication of desire in the rich
isolation and spiritual suicide in the
poor envy and murder for they have been
given rights but have not been shown the
means of satisfying their wants
they maintain that the world is getting
more and more united more and more bound
together in brotherly community as it
overcomes distance and sets thoughts
flying through the air
but put no faith in such a bond of union
interpreting freedom as the
multiplication and rapid satisfaction of
desire
men distort their own nature for many
senseless and foolish desires and habits
and ridiculous fancies are fostered in
them
now dostoevsky noticed this about
western culture as he observed it from
russia in the year 1880
and he couldn't have known just how
right he was
there's probably never been a better
definition of the modern conception of
freedom than the one that he offers
right there freedom is the
multiplication and satisfaction of
desire
but that's not freedom at all it is as
he points out isolation envy hatred
suicide
that's what this kind of freedom gets
you
you aren't even free to walk down the
aisle of a passenger plane you're left
hampered disabled helpless
screaming out like a child demanding
that the world conform itself to you
you're not gonna find any freedom in
such a life
but you will find when it comes down to
it
that you are ultimately
at the end of the day
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]